[Music]
hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
so i just finished watching the third
episode of apple tv's adaptation of
isaac asimov's foundation series and i
decided i'd review it here from my own
space station orbiting earth in an
alternate dimension it's a long story
don't ask about it anyway this episode
continues to trend from the previous
episodes of only being loosely based off
of asimov's books as there are many
liberties taken with the story
i would say that i enjoyed the first 20
minutes of the episode the most
it was interesting to get to learn more
about the genetic dynasty where it came
from and how it actually works there are
always three brothers brother don who is
the youngest brother day who's the
middle brother and brother dusk who is
the oldest now it seems that at a
predetermined time brother dusk ascends
quote unquote and is killed so that a
new brother don can be allowed to be
born into the world now all of this is
done by way of cloning
and it's been going on for 400 years at
least
since the time before the space elevator
was even constructed
now it appears in this episode that all
of this the cloning process as well as
the main duty of taking care of the
emperor when he's brother dusk as well
as advising day and dusk in their
political tactics as well as just being
a companion falls to dim rizelle who is
some kind of a.i
now the character dimmersell does exist
in the book but is
in a completely different incarnation
and i don't know how much of what is
written in asimov's books that they're
going to actually use as far as this
character
the genetic dynasty as i mentioned
before is not in the books at all but it
is an interesting concept i think and
it's particularly interesting when you
consider it in the context of what led
trantor to fall ultimately in the books
leading to the collapse of the galactic
empire entirely
a lot of it had to do with trantor's
inability to handle the administrative
demands of an entire galactic
civilization
and it also had a lot to do with the
complacency of those in power and i just
look at a man who chooses to clone
himself over and over and over so he can
be emperor over and over and over i
can't help but think that because
he will
ultimately never offer anything new
he won't be able to evolve
quickly enough
with the changing empire and the new
state of things as more and more
threatens the stability of the galaxy
now that could be changing there were
some hints in this episode that the new
iteration of
don
is
perhaps a bit different
choosing to have the mural erased
instead of continuing the process of
painting it as all of his predecessors
have done
now obviously dim rozelle is all tied up
into this we just don't know exactly how
she's definitely got plans that have
been in the works for a really long time
another curious thing that we learn
about her in this episode is that she
does
she definitely feels a certain degree of
love for all of the iterations of the
empire and i wonder to what degree she
influenced the original empire to go
through with this whole cloning thing
watched over by her these are all
mysteries that are being set up to
hopefully be solved in the future
episodes
and i'm looking to learning more about
this whole plot line and seeing it
unfold so there's also a few time jumps
in this episode we see
the empire 400 years ago we see the
construction of the face elevator at the
beginning of the construction of the
space elevator and then it jumps to 19
years after the destruction of the space
elevator and then it jumps 17 more years
and we see the most recent iterations
of
the brothers day dusk and dawn and i
imagine that these are the ones that
we'll be continuing to deal with in the
next episode
in the second part of this episode we
get into what life is like for the
people on terminus
this part of the episode i definitely
thought dragged a little bit in
comparison to the first part of the
episode
they are taking a lot of things from the
books and mixing them around and making
them a little bit different
first of all mayor hardin is warden
harden and this and it looks as though
the first selden crisis is happening a
lot sooner than it happened in the book
now in the book the first selden crisis
happens about 50 years after they take
up residence on terminus and if i
remember correctly in this episode it
was only about
it doesn't state exactly how long but it
seems to have only been about 20 years
at maximum just judging by the age of
warden hardin
so in the books uh harry selden does
leave behind a vault
and in the book it's actually set to
open at a specific time and everyone on
terminus is actually preparing to see
what's in the vault and preparing for
what happens when it opens but it looks
like in the show they're setting up a
different kind of mystery involving it
and it reminds me a lot of actually dan
simmons hyperion novels because in the
hyperion books there are these
mysterious objects on the distant world
of hyperion called the time tombs and
the time tombs basically emit these
anti-entropic fields which suddenly
begin to expand
for some reason and no one knows so in
this episode when they talk about the
field surrounding the
vault expanding i couldn't help but
think of hyperion
in this episode it appears that the
expansion of the fields around the vault
has something to do with the fact that
an acrion is planning something and
trying to sneak to terminus even though
it is illegal for the outside world to
interfere with what the encyclopedists
are doing on terminus
i have to admit i spent this whole
section of the show waiting for the
vault to open
because
slight spoiler here if you don't want to
hear this and jump like 10 seconds
in the book inside of the vault it's a
hologram of selden that tells them
something about the crisis they're going
to face so this episode being called the
mathematician's ghost i thought for sure
that was going to be that but it turns
out that the vault did not open at all
they're going to draw it out a little
bit longer and tease the vault for a
little bit longer
understandable but it did kind of for me
take the wind out of the episode a
little bit i was left just slightly
disappointed at the end when i when the
vault didn't open it kind of like sucked
the wind out of it for me just a little
bit
but ultimately i understand why they're
holding out on getting to the mystery of
what is inside of the vault there is a
moment in this episode where harden is
shown
a representation of harry selden's
psycho history calculations and
predictions
and she's asked if she sees anything in
it
and for a second i thought that she was
going to understand psycho history
suddenly just by looking and i thought
please don't do this that's not how it
works do not do this like she can
magically understand it for no reason
but they didn't do that thankfully and i
just want to say i'm really happy that
they didn't go in that direction because
i felt like that would have ultimately
been a mistake that it would be that
would have exposed a fundamental like
misunderstanding of how psycho history
is supposed to work in the book so
that's not the direction that they went
and i'm happy that that didn't happen
now what i want to know is how much of
this show is going to involve
harden on terminus dealing with the
first selden crisis
because i don't want to see that for the
next
four or five episodes i would really
rather they continue to jump
and continue to show the
bureaucratic and administrative failures
that led to the collapse of the galactic
empire as well as the building blocks of
the new galactic empire that is what i'm
most interested in seeing that is what
the books are ultimately about and i
hope this show doesn't get lost
into trying to do trophy things just to
satisfy an audience that doesn't really
care about hard science fiction
but i think the jury is still out on
that and i did
ultimately enjoy this episode although i
thought like i said it dragged a little
bit at the end
and i was kind of hoping that it kind of
went in a different direction and had a
more satisfying ending
now there was no mention in this episode
of gail dornick or the character rach
who i didn't realize that was supposed
to be rage from
the books who is a character in the
prequel books
um because this character is really
really different from the way he's
depicted in the book so i i didn't even
think that that was him but the
character rach who in my last review i
said i didn't know who he was and he
wasn't from the book that's who that was
i guess i just missed his name or
something but they weren't in this
episode at all so we don't really get to
know what happened to him after
harry seldon's death so i guess they're
holding out that mystery as well and as
well as the mystery of where gail
dornick is and where she's off to
without spoiling too many things there
are people in the books that have
certain abilities called mentality
abilities and it is possible that gail
dornick in the show has mentality
abilities there is another character
that was mentioned in the first episode
the mule who is a huge character later
on the books so maybe galdornik is tied
into that storyline somehow since she is
narrating a lot of what's happening
throughout the show so that is also one
of the essential mysteries that remains
to be seen thanks for watching guys make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
well were we even watching the same
episode that review was straight garbage
you're the sorriest excuse for a
youtuber i've ever seen and you could do
better if i had my own youtube channel i
would have 40 billion subscribers then
start your own youtube channel i mean
it's free like anybody can do it like do
it and then you'll be finished
okay
stop [ __ ] commenting [ __ ] on my
videos
sick of the [ __ ]
so
[Music]
you